Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 187. 187, wir wollen sprechen über den internationalen Fußball und vielleicht bekomme ich auch meine Sprachstörungen in Griff. Mal sehen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir tun jetzt einfach so, als wäre das hier live und das wird jetzt einfach genauso im Podcast landen. Tja, manchmal verhaspelt sich der Moderator seines Namens, Max Jakob Ost, der Etgenetzer auf Twitter, schon bei der Begrüßung. Deshalb sind wir doch alle sehr froh, ich am allermeisten, dass ich hier nicht den meisten Redenanteil haben soll, sondern meine Gäste. Und da habe ich auch in dieser Woche eine schöne Runde, die ich begrüßen darf, zum einen Mario Rieker, unter anderem von der ZAUN und natürlich vom Serie Amore Podcast, einem Podcast mit einem allein schon wunderschönen Titel. Hallo Mario.
Ja, interessante Perspektive, auch mit dem, was du sagst, dass Norwich einen, in Anführungszeichen, deutschen Fußballspiel, das ist ja auch dann eigentlich interessant zu sehen, wie das in einer anderen Liga funktioniert. Das sage ich aber natürlich als jemand, der den deutschen Fußball sehr, sehr, sehr intensiv verfolgt für den Rasenfunk. Also das war eine der Entlassungen. Dann hast du Newcastle United schon angesprochen. Da gab es auch viel Berichterstattung drüber, die zumindest auch bei mir aufgeschlagen ist. David Hau ist jetzt da der neue Trainer geworden. Was ist denn von ihm und von Newcastle generell zu erwarten? Die Aufregung ist nicht wirklich geringer geworden in den letzten Wochen.
Also ich mag den Trainer sehr gerne. Lange Jahre bei Bournemouth gearbeitet, zwischenzeitlich hat er es mal woanders probiert, aber nie glücklich geworden da. Und ich vertrete immer die Meinung, wenn der ein Ausländer wäre, dann hätte er einen viel, viel besseren Stand in England gehabt, weil der sensationelle Arbeit zum Teil mit einem äußerst limitierten Kader bei Bournemouth geleistet hat. Und mich hat es bis heute erstaunt, dass nie ein Klub, der einen Trainer gesucht hat, an ihn ernsthaft ran zu gehen, schien. Also es hätte durchaus auch mal sein können, dass Tottenham eventuell überlegt oder Everton. Das wären so klassisch Klubs, von denen ich gedacht hätte, dass sie vielleicht mal an den denken. Das ist ein sehr smarter Typ. Das ist ein nicht immer ganz lauter, aber vor allen Dingen sehr, sehr fleißiger Trainer, der viel über Standards kommt, also wirklich die absoluten Basics seinen Spielern mitgibt und dann aber auch gerne recht schnell nach vorne denkt. Also es ist ein geflügeltes Zitat. Da ist er jetzt auch nicht der Einzige, wahrscheinlich dem das anzuhaften ist, aber dass er sagt, ich gewinne lieber Spieler, als dass ich versuche, sie nicht zu verlieren. Und das hat ganz gut gezeigt, was er mit Bournemouth getan hat. Okay, letztlich dann abgestiegen, aber das war ja auch irgendwann nur eine Frage der Zeit, dass du mit diesem Kader, mit dieser Mannschaft absteigen musst, ist jetzt bei Newcastle. Ich meine, ehrlicherweise ist Newcastle –das Problem war, sie haben mit den letzten Trainern –und Rafa Benitez ist ein ausgezeichneter, deswegen hat es nie Probleme gegeben –aber Steve Bruce versuchte, ein Defensiv-Team zu coachen. Dafür waren sie aber deutlich zu schlecht organisiert und deswegen haben sie viele Gegentore gefangen und waren aber zahlenmäßig sehr, sehr tief gestanden, sodass sie an sich ein bis zwei Offensivspieler hatten. Einer, Saint-Maximin, ist mal überragend und dann vier Spiele lang völlig wild und nicht zu sehen. Und dann kommt wieder ein Harry-Dribbling, das dann zum Teil auch funktioniert, und sie haben vorne drin Carl und Wilson. Aber wenn die beiden abzumelden waren –und Premier League-Isten sind in der Regel smart und haben das recht schnell gemacht –dann gab es wenig mit Newcastle. Das heißt, so wie dieser Kader, der in den letzten Jahren auch wenig verstärkt worden ist, so wie dieser Kader bislang gespielt hat, weiß ich noch gar nicht richtig, das abzubilden, was Hau jetzt versuchen wird, mit diesem Kader zu tun. Und ich meine, ganz so lang wird er sich mit dem auch nicht mehr beschäftigen müssen, weil in rund zwei Monaten wird er ja auf Shopping-Tour gehen dürfen und wird dann sicherlich auch zumindest ein paar völlig überteuerte Transfers in den Kader inkludieren dürfen.
Und glaubst du, das kann er? Kann man das bewerten mit seinen Trainerstationen? Bornmuth hast du genannt, Burnley dazwischen?
Ich hoffe, dass er es nicht alleine machen muss, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil das bedeuten würde, dass Newcastle bis zu dem Zeitpunkt noch immer gar keinen Director of Football hat. Und Amanda Stavely, die jetzt sozusagen als Gesicht des Vereins aufgebaut wird, die hat, glaube ich, selber Lust, Sportdirektorin zu spielen. Das hat sie aber nicht im Kreuz sportlich gesehen. Deswegen würde ich mir, ich glaube, das wäre sogar auch die wichtigere Position, dass sie jetzt recht schnell jemanden finden, der sich darum kümmern wird, dem Verein eine Strategie zu geben, gerade weil eben so viel Geld da ist. Ansonsten werden sie drei, vier Tote sterben, bevor es dann irgendwann mal in die richtige Richtung geht oder bevor Saudi Arabien vielleicht auch gar keinen Bock mehr hat drauf. Also aus Sicht Newcastles wäre das, glaube ich, das Empfehlenswert, dass sie so schnell wie möglich jetzt da einen Plan reinzubekommen. Aber ich traue es trotzdem Eddie Howe auch zu, mit seinem Wissen. Und er hat mit Jason Tindall eine ausgezeichnete Nummer 2, der ihm dann auch gefolgt ist bei Bournemouth, kurz als Cheftrainer. Das war nicht so sein Ding. Aber er hat eine ausgezeichnete Nummer 2 da. Ich denke schon, dass die beiden in der Lage sind, Spieler zu identifizieren. Vielleicht aber, und das ist ja das Newcastle, da geht die Öffentlichkeit davon aus. Und ich glaube, die Besitzer schafft auch, dass die jetzt ganz schnell die ganz großen Namen holen werden. Ich würde denken, dass Eddie Howe smart genug ist, um genau das nicht zu tun, sondern jetzt erstmal Funktionsspieler holt, die sein System weiterbringen, dass er da implementieren will. Und da ist eine Menge zu tun, weil der Kader ist nicht besonders stark.
Kurze Frage von mir an dich, Uli. Findest du, Eddie Howe ist da die richtige, die schlüssige, die gute Wahl für Newcastle? Oder hätte Newcastle ins höhere Trainerregal greifen müssen?
Ich habe es ja ganz kurz schon mal vorhin angedeutet. Ich halte den durchaus, wenn man in Regalen denken mag, den mindestens ein, zwei Kasten höher als in der, in der letztlich geschoben wird. Ich freue mich, dass der wieder zurück ist in der Liga. Ich habe dessen Fußball immer sehr geschätzt. Ich habe immer gefunden, dass er mit seinen Teams klar overperformed hat in allen Ligen im Übrigen. Also hat sie auch perfekt angepasst an seine Umgebungen jeweils. Und deswegen freue ich mich, dass er jetzt da ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Typ, so wie er als Mensch zu sein scheint, ich kenne ihn ja jetzt nicht persönlich, aber so wie er als Mensch zu sein scheint, ob der dann mit diesem riesengroßen und jetzt ganz unorganisch wachsenden Umfeld klarkommt. Da habe ich noch ein paar Fragezeichen. Aber ich meine, das muss er halt jetzt lernen. Und ich bin einfach froh, dass er in der Premier League ist, weil der gehört dahin.
Und dann haben wir noch Aston Villa, die du genannt hast. Die haben nach Jack Greelish im Sommer jetzt auch ihren Trainer Dean Smith verloren. Hängt beides miteinander zusammen?
Ja, also nicht nur. Aber das ist schon ein ganz, ganz großer Grund, dass Jack Greelish so ziemlich alles bestimmt hat. Und vor allen Dingen das Spiel bei Aston Villa. Und den haben sie versucht zu ersetzen, auch mit ordentlich viel Geld zu ersetzen. Aber der Spieler, der –also eins zu eins geht eh nicht. Das kann sich Aston Villa auch nicht leisten. Bei all dem Geld, das da dahinter steckt, kommt ein solcher Spieler nicht nach Birmingham. Noch nicht, mag sich noch ändern, aber noch nicht. Und Buendia, den sie verpflichtet haben, ja, reicht nicht. Also der kommt aus der zweiten englischen Liga. Da war er wirklich alles überragend. Hat auch in der Premier League schon in der Saison davor gezeigt, dass er kreativ sein kann und so weiter. Aber eher von der rechten Seite kommen. Der musste eine etwas zentralere Rolle bei Villa einnehmen. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Und dazu kommen einige auch individuelle Formschwächen jetzt im Vergleich zur letzten Saison. Dann auch Dean Smith, der angefangen hat, seine eigenen Überzeugungen über Bord zu werfen. Öfter mal auch gewechselt hat in den Formationen. Schlüsselspieler aus irgendwelchen Gründen aus den Startformationen gezogen hat. Und dann ist da irgendwann eine Gemenge Lage geworden, bei der ich es dann wiederum nachvollziehen kann. Auch da finde ich es irgendwie schade. Und wenn man das jetzt aus der Geschichte begründet, würde man sagen, ihr hattet es jetzt mit Trainer Chaos probiert in den Jahren zuvor. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Jetzt schien es endlich, Stabilität zu geben. Jetzt macht ihr wieder was. Okay. Andererseits sind jetzt nicht nur fünf Niederlagen in Folge, sondern aus den letzten 36 Premier League Spielen haben sie 40 Punkte geholt. Und sie dachten, dass sie einen Schritt machen können und eher in Richtung Europa League ran können. Und da wollen sie mittelfristig hin. Und deswegen kann ich sogar verstehen, dass man da jetzt sagt, wenn man die Ergebnisse sieht und aber auch die Art und Weise, wie sie zum Teil entstanden sind, dann kann ich das sogar halbwegs nachvollziehen. Und letzter Satz dazu vielleicht auch noch. Dean Smith hatte nach dieser Übernahme von diesem neuen Konsortium, die unter anderem auch die Finger bei den Milwaukee Bucks in der NBA drin haben, und die sind ja bekanntlich Meister geworden in der vergangenen Saison, entsprechend schnell möchten die da an sich auch vorankommen. Die haben nie gedacht, dass Dean Smith der Name ist, der sie weiterbringen könnte, sondern die haben den immer nur als Transitionstrainer gesehen. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist die Entscheidung auch nicht so schwergefallen. Der Finger war permanent schon am Abzug.
Ja, das fasst das, glaube ich, ganz gut zusammen. Willa baut uns so ein bisschen die Brücke auch zu zwei Niederlagen, die jetzt am letzten Spieltag, dem 11. passiert sind, die viel diskutiert wurden. Nein, Entschuldigung, nicht zu... Da war ich im falschen Tap. Manchester United hat ja viel früher schon gegen B ja verloren. Da kommt ja der Sieg her. Das hatte ich mir einfach falsch gemerkt. Aber sowohl United als auch Liverpool haben ihre letzten Spiele verloren. Lass mal bei Liverpool anfangen, denn bei Manchester United habe ich das Gefühl, wir wiederholen uns irgendwie in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen. Wie ist denn das einzuordnen? Das letzte Mal, als wir über Liverpool gesprochen haben, waren sie doch absolut überzeugend. Sowohl international als auch national schienen oder scheinen für mich –ich möchte das jetzt gar nicht in die Vergangenheit schon setzen –eine der besten Mannschaften Europas aktuell zu sein. Eine Niederlage kann ja auch mal passieren. Was für eine Art von Niederlage war es denn?
Ja, ich glaube schon eine, die man einfach auch da reinrechnen muss. Irgendwann muss es halt mal passieren. Jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, 26 in Folge nicht verloren. Jetzt kommt West Ham, die ganz viele Dinge ganz richtig machen im Moment und auch noch mal gezeigt haben. Das würde ich in dem Fall sogar vorne dran stellen. Das ist keine Liverpool-Schwäche. Das war jetzt definitiv nicht ganz sauber. Das war nicht der allerkonzentrierteste Auftritt. Das Timing in den Pressing-Sequenzen hat nicht so gepasst. Die Auslöser nicht richtig gesehen. Dann ist ja ganz oft ein Tag schon so richtig gebraucht, wenn das so passiert für Liverpool. Aber auf der anderen Seite –und das ist, glaube ich, viel hervorhebenswerter –war es eine unglaublich starke Performance. Vielleicht sogar auch die stärkste jetzt in den letzten beiden Jahren unter David Moyes, in denen Dinge passiert sind, die ich bis heute nicht glauben kann, weil ich David Moyes eigentlich schon als Dead Man Walking hatte im gesamten englischen Fußball. Und erstaunlich, was der aus West Ham gemacht hat. Deswegen würde ich die Ligenanlage Liverpools nicht allzu hoch hängen. Im Gegenteil, ich habe sie nach wie vor in dem Cluster drin. Und da hatte ich sie ja vor der Saison nicht unbedingt bei den Top-Dreien, die es letztlich in Sachen Meisterschaft unter sich entscheiden werden, Chelsea City und eben Liverpool.
Also fürs Tabellenbild noch kurz, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Chelsea Platz 1 mit 26 Punkten, jetzt auch nur unentschieden gespielt. Am Wochenende City und West Ham mit 23 Punkten dahinter, Liverpool 22 Punkte. Das heißt, 4 Punkte Rückstand aktuell auf Chelsea. Und auf Rang 5 noch ganz kurz, Uli, der FC Arsenal. Die haben sich so ein kleines Särchen aufgebaut und sind jetzt längere Zeit ungeschlagen und haben sich damit mit der spektakulären Tordifferenz von 13 zu 13 auf Rang 5 vorgeschoben. Alles wieder gut?
Ja, im Moment sieht es so aus. Wir hatten ja das letzte Mal gesprochen, als sie zur ersten Länderspielpause ganz am Ende der Tabelle standen. Mit, ich glaube, was waren das, 0 zu 9 Toren oder irgendwie so ähnlich. Und sich haben abschießen lassen von Manchester City. Seither –Arteta ist ein cleverer Trainer, das muss man ihm echt lassen. Der hat jetzt ein System für sich gefunden, implementiert, das die richtigen Ergebnisse für den Moment holt und die richtigen Spieler zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in ihre Entwicklungsphase an die Positionen schiebt, wo sie nicht ganz so extrem viel Verantwortung zu übernehmen haben. Und es funktioniert. Und jetzt haben sie sich gegen Watford auch in dem Spiel mal zur Wehr gesetzt, dass sie typischerweise noch vor Monaten verloren hätten, weil sie einfach nicht so mit dem ständigen Druck klargekommen wären. Das haben sie jetzt 1 vor allem zu 0 gewonnen. Und deswegen ist da der Befund für den Moment äußerst positiv. Das war ja nicht immer so. Das war ja auch schon kurz vor der Entlassung. Aber für den Moment würde ich sagen, Ateta zeigt mir gerade wieder. Und das ist so fies, weil ich den nicht einzuschätzen weiß. Jedes Mal, wenn ich denke, jetzt kenne ich die Wahrheit über ihn, kommt ein ganz neues Kapitel dazu. Aber das spricht ja für ihn, dass der in dieser Trainerstation für sich selbst auch unheimlich viel Erfahrung sammelt.
Also dann werden wir Arsenal einfach weiter genau im Blick behalten. Ich glaube, das macht so ganz gut diese Sendung hier fertig. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit, dass ihr euch hier zugeschaltet habt. Aus aller Herren Länder möchte ich fast sagen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Könnt ihr natürlich auch auf Twitter folgen. Werde ich verlinken in den Show Notes. Danke dir, lieber Uli. Dann danke an Alex Truica, wird natürlich ebenfalls verlinkt. Danke dir, Alex. Gerne. Danke, Mario Rieker, vom Serie Amore Podcast unter anderem. Danke, Mario. Und danke an Alexis Menuge, direkt aus Paris zugeschaltet. Wir hatten immer mal wieder irgendwelche Krähen im Hintergrund, aber sie haben immer an den richtigen Stellen gekräht.
Und danke an mir und an die Kollegen.
Dann euch lieben Dank, liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie ihr dieses Format so empfindet. Der Rasenfunk bleibt werbe-, payball- und sponsorenfrei. Wir zahlen unseren Gästen einen Honorar. Das heißt, wenn ihr uns unterstützt, unterstützt ihr auch sie. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie ihr das tun könnt. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. In diesem Sinne, bis bald. Passt auf euch auf, bleibt gesund. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Egal, ob im Kurzfass oder der Schlusskonferenz.